hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we'll be discussing the question of
whether or not the soul of one of the
most dark Wizards to ever live Lord
Voldemort would have survived if a
dementor had performed the infamous
Dementors kiss on him what is the
dementor's kiss dementas are certainly a
special form of nightmare fuel which
means that if you've read about them or
seen them in the Harry Potter films
you've likely found it quite difficult
to forget them or what they look like
but just in case for those of you who
may be new to The Wizarding World of
Harry Potter Dementors that the ghoulish
looking magical beings that float around
like a bunch of grim reapers in search
of their very own Ebenezer Scrooge to
torment and in all honesty they look
exactly like the typical Grim Reaper
evolved with the exception of the Scythe
of course there's also a lot of them
whereas in common law there's usually
just one lone Grim Reaper presumably
because cause this figure is typically a
representation of death in any case the
Dementors in Harry Potter are terrifying
ghouls who enjoy gorging themselves or
none other than human Souls this
delightful Act is known within the
Wizarding World as the dementor's case
aka the sucking of a person's soul out
of their body when the dementor's kiss
is performed the dementor pulls back its
Hood clamps its jaw around the victim's
mouth and consumes their soul yikes as
Dementors were used to help Safeguard
The Wizarding prison of Azkaban it's no
surprise that the dementis kiss was
sometimes performed upon criminals as a
sentence decreed by the ministry of
magic it's rumored that the act of the
kiss was possibly reserved for the
specific crime of escaping from Azkaban
since several very serious criminals
like Bellatrix Lestrange were never
sentenced to the dementor's case this
seems a bit odd since the dementor's
kiss was viewed by many witches and
wizards to actually be a fate worse than
death
presumably this is because the Dementors
kiss would leave the victim an empty
husk of a human alive but not really
just a body without the ability to think
or feel and the mind in a persistent
vegetative state the witch or wizard
irretrievably gone for this reason it
was widely suspected that anyone who had
the kiss performed on them was unable to
return as a ghost since their soul had
been consumed by the dementor it is said
that no one truly knows what happens to
the soul when it's ingested by a
dementor throughout the Harry Potter
series we see Dementors perform or
almost perform the kiss on a number of
occasions from their attempt to consume
the three Souls of Harry Potter Hermione
Granger and Sirius Black near the Black
Lake in the Prisoner of Azkaban and to
their performance of the kiss on Barty
Crouch Jr in the Goblet of Fire there's
even that time that Harry saves his
ungrateful cousin Dudley dursley from
two Dementors in little whinging far
away from the grounds of both Hogwarts
Castle and Azkaban which brings us to
today's question if a dementor had
performed the kiss on Lord Voldemort
what would have happened would his soul
have been able to survive the kiss why
or why not to properly answer this
question I think we must address it in
steps carefully considering the
different stages of Voldemort's life to
start with if the dementis kiss had been
performed on a young Tom Riddle before
he became Voldemort I'm quite confident
that he would not have survived instead
Tom would have become a vegetable and
the dark lord would have never come to
be I believe this to be true regardless
of whether Tom was a little boy or the
ruthless and cunning young man he became
near the end of his education at
Hogwarts I think it's also fairly safe
to say that if a dementor had sucked
Voldemort's soul out of his body before
the dark lord had created his horcruxes
even if he was already rising in power
as he was in the 1970s I don't think
Voldemort's Soul would have been able to
withstand the effects of the dementor's
case that is I suppose unless he'd
already begun making horcruxes and
hiding his soul across the country but
more on that in just a minute in any
case this all leads us to the real
question after splitting his soul so
many times what would the Dementors even
have to suck out of Voldemort's body and
with this Act of the Dementors kiss be
enough to kill the mind and soul of
Voldemort despite the majority of his
soul being fragmented and stored in
horcruxes throughout the country to
answer this question I think we must
first consider a well-known fan Theory
out there regarding Dementors and Harry
Potter according to the theory Dementors
were more attracted to Harry throughout
the series than they were to other
witches and wizards this is said to be
due in large part to the fact that Harry
had more than just his soul in his body
he also had part of Voldemort soul in
there this of course was the result of
Harry being one of Voldemort's
unsuspecting horcruxes and so with this
theory in mind it stands to reason that
Voldemort would have been less appealing
to Dementors than any other witch or
wizard since he had what only 1 8 of a
soul in his body would Dementors have
even been interested in performing the
dementor's kiss on the Dark Lord's
almost soulless form or would it have
been a waste of their time and efforts I
mean surely if he was the only person
about they take him for what he had and
so if they had performed the kiss on him
at this point in his life what would
have happened since Voldemort was
somewhat of a shell of a wizard already
devoid of much Soul a fragment of a
fragment if you will would his soul have
been able to survive in a way that
others could not this is a particularly
interesting question since during his
second rise to power in the 1990s his
body was newly created out of blood and
other gross things made specifically to
host a bit of his soul that had remained
after his Avada kadav recurs bounced
back at him in his attempt to murder an
infant Harry Potter would it matter that
Voldemort's body the thing hosting the
remnants of his soul was not his
original form for example it may have
been possible for the body which was
created specifically to house and
protect this piece of his soul to have
been able to resist the dementor's kiss
and fight back almost like another
horcrux I'm I'm imagining a dementor
either going in for the kiss only to
sense that this vessel was not
susceptible and backing off all the
dementor clamping down on Voldemort's
face only to have the Dark Lord's body
close off to protect the bit of his soul
that was in there fight back and
irrevocably damage the dementor in the
process from another perspective if a
dementor was indeed able to perform the
kiss on Voldemort I suppose you could
argue that the Dementors were such
powerful beings that the act of the kiss
could have triggered the other pieces of
the Dark Lord's soul to come flying to
the location of the dementor and
Voldemort the magic wielded by the
Dementors seems to be shrouded pun
intended in so much mystery due to their
deadly nature and lack of interest in
shall we say Chit Chat and so it's not
outside of the realm of possibility that
in sucking out Voldemort's Soul they
could have pulled the horcruxes from the
far reaches of the country with their
special brand of magical abilities
and yet even with these two former
theories I find myself most drawn to one
that seems to me to be the simplest I
think that if a dementor had performed
the dementis kiss on Voldemort as he was
during his second rise to power in the
90s the dementor would have sucked out
the piece of his soul that was in there
and his body would have gone into a
vegetative state yet since Voldemort had
split his soul so many times to account
for something exactly like this
happening other bits of his soul would
have continued to live on in his
multiple horcruxes one of his soul
fragments could then have been
presumably reinstated into this body so
in all likelihood the dark lord would
have instructed his band of most trusted
Death Eaters on what to do in the event
of something like this take his body or
create a new one if need be to the
nearest horcrux and reunite that part of
his soul with the host meaning that even
though the piece of his soul that was in
his body wouldn't have been able to
survive the dementor's kiss Voldemort
could have endured and survived it's
Scrappy but it works and with that we've
come to the end of another video what
did you think do you think Voldemort
could have survived the dementor's kiss
please share your thoughts in the
comments below and as always if you
enjoyed this video don't forget to like
it and subscribe to the channel until
next time remember it does not do to
dwell on dreams and forget to live